[Music]
i'd have said they were crazy
just think sally when the great pumpkin
rises out of the pumpkin patch we'll be
here to see him
what's that
[Music]
what's
that i hear the great pumpkin
love the linus in the animated classic
it's the great pumpkin charlie brown our
hero linus awaits the arrival of a very
special squash but it's not the only
autumn sensation that appears just once
a year these are the months when the
flavor of pumpkin spice shows up
seemingly everywhere and it all began
with one wildly popular beverage
we traveled to seattle to meet the man
responsible for planting the seed that
started it all
it's the coffee confection that came to
define a whole season
with three letters familiar to starbucks
baristas and customers around the world
p s l
the pumpkin spice latte and we've got
this man peter dukes to thank for it is
this where it all began this is where it
all began right here in starbucks
seattle headquarters in 2001 you were
the father of psl
that's what some say yes
now director of global growth in
concepts back then dukes was in charge
of espresso drinks for the company fresh
off the holiday success of peppermint
mocha
we were asked hey can we come out with
something for the fall so we came up
with 100 different ideas and whittled it
down to 10. we had about 500 customers
look at these 10 concepts so we got back
the results
chocolate and caramel
oh yeah i'll buy that for sure cinnamon
solid pretty well this is something that
people don't know or are not aware of
pumpkin spice latte never had a chance
that it was going to get to prototype so
what you're saying it was the flavor
that almost wasn't it was the flavor
that almost wasn't and what saved it was
it was a unique beverage what we didn't
know at that time was whether or not it
was something that our customers would
want to try
so making that winning flavor would be
no piece of cake although it did involve
a slice of something else we brought in
pumpkin pies into our r d lab and
actually just poured shots of espresso
on them and ate them
pumpkin spice latte and for 18 years
customers have been eating them up hey
pumpkin meat spice you guys are going to
be best friends with more than 500
million sold since their 2003 debut this
probably is something that psychology
and economics and marketing classes
could be studying for ages this is the
first pumpkin spice latte of the year
neurobiologist catherine franson of the
science museum of virginia believes that
all that success comes down to science
pumpkin spice has the ability to really
reach into the center of our memories at
a very emotional level but at the core
of that is sugar we actually encode the
memories of what's associated with the
sugar for example the smell of pumpkin
spice but it's psl's high sugar content
that also drove complaints from health
conscious consumers along with the
original recipes use of artificial
flavors and the absence of any real
pumpkin i think it spurred us to think a
little harder how we could even make it
better coffee is being roasted which
thomas prather starbucks vice president
of brand and product marketing says led
to a recipe change in 2015.
i think it actually woke up the industry
a bit to look inside and say how can we
have cleaner ingredients how can we be
more innovative and what we're
delivering to our customers and it
pushed us all forward
and pushed the hype as well
that's the year the psl got its own
twitter handle and official instagram
account
then two years later starbucks live
streamed the early arrival of its psl
debuting it in late august it logged
more than eight million hits
psl brought fun to coffee and brought
people that weren't purest
into
the cafe culture fun to coffee yeah so
if you think about coffee before pslb in
the early 2000s cappuccino please it was
you had a cappuccino or you had just a
dopio espresso and once we started
making it more approachable people
started kind of thinking of it this is
more than just utilitarian drink that
i'm going to get before work and that
led to a profusion of products including
seasonal beverages even an expansion of
his spaces like this giant reserve bar
and bistro in select cities
just in time to celebrate the company's
golden anniversary would all of this be
possible if not for psl pumpkin spice
latte i think pumpkin spiced latte and
the success of that gave us the
confidence that we could do whatever we
wanted to do with coffee it took off to
a whole other level that again nobody
ever could have predicted and for
legions of psl loyalists there simply is
no substitute for that ultimate fall fix
can you show me how to make one i would
be happy to let's do it all right
right here here's we have to make our uh
our psl
just dump it all in there you go get a
little swirl
talent you look like you know what
you're doing
[Music]
mine's a little messier
cheers ears
[Music]
happy fall peter thank you
[Laughter]
any question i like my bsl
but you know this is also the flavor
that people love to hate i mean tom
oliver i think is at the top of the list
but this is this is uh something people
just grimace at and the folks over at
starbucks just say you know what they
taught us a lesson on the flavors uh the
real pumpkin needed to be there maybe
yes that's a big part of it yeah but uh
but really uh you know they got to get
over it i'm surprised they gave you a
whipped cream dispenser yeah that's a
good access to a large it's not bad
though it's a good job it it tasted
pretty good too i have to say i know how
to make a mean pso not clean neat
i mean
that doesn't matter as long as you're
able to drink it that's all that matters
yeah they are good man